as we have seen over the years many
times some patrons try to provoke
Muslims by insulting the Prophet or so
we have in our back central core that
engaged though about two hours from here
a so-called pastor and I say so called
because I leave here who lives up to his
Christian values
he created the way around just as in
Ojai and wanted to burn so he had on the
ninth anniversary of September 11th at
RADA to try the Quran has guilty for
causing Wars and misery in the world and
tried to tie them up on and Muslims to
be responsible for what happened on 9/11
and he garnered a lot of attention from
the media because the media loves
controversy and I felt as the leader in
Central Florida I have
and talk to this person if he was you
know unaware of what Islam is
I'll talk to him and teach him but if he
was really troublemaker I have to stop
him from insulting Islam and 1.6 billion
Muslims and to stop them from burning
our scripture so on invitation of the
mayor of Gainesville and after an event
engaged all day over million spiritual
leaders I thought that a man he really
recommended that I go and meet Terry
Jones that's his name Eddie
so I weapon tried to speak to him
one-on-one and found him to be you know
full of hate ignorant person but
nevertheless I was determined to stop
that from burning the papaya because it
was happening right at the end of
Ramadan the month of the Quran and right
you know but on the second day of Eid I
said what an insult to all of us
worldwide but Hamill after two days of
everything ago she ends I was able to
convince this dude to cancel it and to
cancel all the spectacle and he was
exposed to the whole world for being a
hateful person being a crazy person and
everywhere I went
non-muslims have you know this symptoms
from him and said he does not represent
them and this side I think we want
showed that Muslims are not the crazy
ones were committing something but this
is the hateful person who was trying to
provoke Muslims to do something
so Allah Spano Ta'ala used me in that
opportunity to to stop this man from his
evil ever we eat a strong event isn't it
that if someone even insult Jesus peace
be upon isn't that right definitely was
one of the mightiest messengers that God
Almighty sent with the same message
today Moses came with Abraham the same
essence worship the Creator consecration
and he's mentioned how many times in the
Quran Jesus did bless his mother right
so he I told him we love and respect
Jesus I told him you know that the
method I followed with him was quoting
to him from the Bible says we believe in
the gospel
we believe in the Torah and that's why
I'm talking to you as a religious man to
religious man you know follow your own
book I said with Jesus do what you're
doing
there's nothing exactly that's the very
verse I said you know Jesus said love
your neighbor and I'm your neighbor you
know I'm not talking to you of other
people overseas but I'm right here with
any Muslim in Central Florida
who hurt you or come by your church and
is anything wrong said no as a matter of
fact except you're the first wisdom I
need says so if you can point out the
Muslim who has insulted you or hurt you
in any way
I'll take Erica but the fact is there's
over fifty thousand Muslims Central
Florida and nobody did anything to you
so you know you have to love your
neighbors and that's what Jesus told you
so he that was one of the many steps
and this is the vernacular language
people use they can connect yourself
I myself was born in Chicago I went to
the Chicago public school systems from
kindergarten are in a high school sports
was something that I've started at a
young age and with sports there's
benefits you know at the same time
there's always some times that social
concerns that you could go through so
one of the things that so what's
happened is that I had many questions
why can't we do this and you especially
your first you know first generation
coming here asking Allah show you why is
this going on why can't we do this why
can't we do that and sometimes father
individuals kind of sorts how about just
because it's helped because the others
are focused on so as I do live going
through the minna MSA days and realizing
these concerns and social issues were a
lot of the kids in special high school
are really getting challenged not about
playing it's why they're not praying are
what they're having these issues with
the opposite gender so as I grew older
thought to myself one of the things is
to write about these challenges because
I know a lot of kids are going through I
was as I was traveling to speak to many
youth I realized you can't get to every
individual but through a book they could
always read about that topic they have
an issue with so that's where I we did
this little survey with kids you know
throughout the United States say what
are the top 10 areas through middle most
women in North America and then from
there we kind of wrote down and said
let's write about these so me and my
cousin Saad decided to write this book
and and hamlets slowly kind of picked up
and taken off here in overseas
today I'm gonna let him because he's
doing you know with ride with us which
is very important you know you know
yesterday there was a topic huh you know
rocking the boat you know so one is
you're on the boat but I'm rocking the
boat you want to take some of the
chances especially sometimes when you're
rocking it and like today's is riding
the wave so you're flying off the boat
so sometimes kids get tempted they want
to take that chance one of the big
things I've realized with kids is it's
not going to happen to me and I call it
the a belief syndrome this serves the
arrogance and that's why the book we
wrote was called war within the hearts
because we realize it's your heart
something that's always going on and
saying yeah I know but I just want to
see just try it
and I won't go too far you know I know
my limits and and that's where we've
seen like you know the challenge of no
you need to stay into the boat
don't you know even when you're on a
boat right now that's you know when the
captain tells you don't put your hand
outside the boat even if you think like
oh I have a lifejacket don't have some
friends around me I filed and I'll swim
back you don't know how big those waves
are and that's one of the big concerns
so you know I really kind of like that
theme of making sure you're secure in
the boat not outside that will not kind
of on the corner of the ball not saying
well I'll just keep just in case I have
a life jacket I'll fall off I know I
could get back but just staying firm
because Allah knows what's best and
they'll fit of laws bow through the
prophets that's the boat you want to go
on to any other vote it might look good
through a veces deception but it is
going to take you to a state of drowning
you know the prophet sallallaahu asylum
clearly stated that you have a mountain
that a lot and is with the genomic group
so woman said listen toughen up the
person who goes by himself
will go into the Hellfire what will
protect us as communities as youth is
sticking together like a pack you know
and and he said in another example that
the wolf will take from the sheep the
one that trained by itself so every time
a youth person as Bella Hadid said think
that they can handle it on their own and
they leave the community they leave the
message life they leave the youth group
and say I'm gonna strike out on my own
they are putting themselves as great
risks they need to really stick with the
denial stick with the youth because they
will constantly remind them of what's
right they will be honest with them and
critiquing them and helping them see the
things they don't see today many youth
you know they love to hear praise from
friends or peers who are not interested
in their well-being however they don't
want to listen to their own brothers or
sisters who may tell them what's wrong
with them you know so they run away from
them we need to be honest with ourselves
and it's simple to understand I wouldn't
know what the sky looked like what the
trees looked like I would have never
seen the faces of my beautiful children
if I didn't have the ability to see how
blessed we are by Allah and obedience is
born out of gratitude
so thank him call upon him establish a
relationship with him forget about the
past take it out of being a ritual and
make it a spiritual experience as long
as not something
yes unclear hazy it's really
straightforward he said it changed his
life he said he saw every single episode
yes indeed Islam is not about following
blindly even the right this life you
have to choose for yourself okay Islam
is by choice not by inheritance so we
have a lot of Muslims today 1.6 billion
Muslims who say we're Muslims but
they'll act like Muslims the vast
majority are not acting or thinking like
Muslims because they inherit with
traditions and practices from their
parents and grandparents without
thinking about them
this Lomb is by the choice and Allah
will hold you responsible for that
choice with the chameleon that you have
and going back to the point that Bella
Hadid was saying you know no Sun this
whole the whole versus is sort of truth
is about too much Sun how North build
the boat and he is a great prophet who
for 950 years was preaching his people
so imagine how long he has been talking
to salsa yet there was no guarantee his
son was with the disbelievers and of the
last minute what he could have saved his
own life he chose to say with the wrong
group and that what happens every day on
the streets you know children of Muslims
they choose to part with their own
parents and their own
and say no I want to stay with my
friends don't know that that is the end
of their you know I have very people who
did that and they could have been alive
and Muslim but they chose bad friendship
and got killed in a drug deal let's take
it to the parents now right so and what
comes to my mind look Islam is beautiful
this is this way of lighting the crater
you know they're such big set up you ha
can worship behind one day Jesus the
other you know mix it with all these
things that aren't sanctioned from the
crater it's clear there is the six
articles of faith Bleakley not like too
many Jews the books that reveal you
mentioned the gospel and it's a Richard
that was given to jesus to Torah that
was given to Moses and its original and
and to be a judgment and then the five
pillars praying you can't pray but you
want to pray you know what I mean I'll
pray you know once a month right by
times a day minimum and the fasting
accepted right these are set but now
there's flexibility and some things tell
us the part where golly
you've been telling about the along one
where he said commenting give me this
great advice that to the parents about
raising their children not how you were
raised but do you know this is a
stinking but they were raised you were
raised in a different time and they're
raising different
how'd he get with the time about
compromising right because sometimes we
bring some of this back agriculture you
just he's going through the rituals but
your heart's not connected to a log the
woman doesn't know really why she's
wearing a job she don't know maybe the
wisdoms behind it did it make sense so
how can we get the parents on the same
page as the children without
compromising so maybe they can change up
two techniques a little bit right
instead of making it seem like it's just
a bunch of rituals right and praying and
you've been praying maybe 50 years you
know what you're saying right and they
threaten them Islam is being used as you
know a lynch to bring them back in order
and that's wrong Islam is beautiful and
we see that parents also push culture on
their children and they dress it as
Islam that if you don't eat biryani
you're committing a sin if you are not
that well I mean if if the kid wants to
eat a burger or a hot dog that's fine
you know but no we insist on cultural
things and we give in on real Islam so
the children grow up in this environment
they feel there is some sort of
hypocrisy there and we need to emphasize
the demon itself not try to import you
know cultural practices that our kids
born here grew up here don't can't
practice them in an American culture
yeah and that culture might be fine and
then the back in their parents original
country but it doesn't work you can't
dress like that here you can't you know
necessarily practice that every day here
so maybe on a need on an international
day but not every day so we have to if
they want to
yes and I think this is where sometimes
we have to use what day they used to you
know a lot of times in the books what
we're trying to tell those kids in
Philly
I lost my thumb knows us like you know
just you know yeah use examples of you
know mercedes-benz when they you know
car a really nice car the person who
makes it has a manuals how exactly you
need to 10,000 miles change the tires
15,000 do this
don't put this gas in there same well
why has given us the Quran and has given
us another prophet muhammad saw some to
tell us exactly how to do it and
sometimes kids either get reality checks
when you know they're not talking about
you know our gender relations like my
man is so good why can't we just kind of
holler after young ladies just to talk I
won't do anything but just the same when
1.8 million girls are the age of 16 last
year had kids you think 1.8 million
under the age of 16 every one out of
every four kids in high school have an
STD people dig that you know it's not
gonna happen
68 percent of eleven year old kids I've
seen adult website cuz oh no it's not
gonna happen to me one of the big
reality is is that we gotta realize when
we talk to parents is that everyone
thinks they have the mashallah child
like it can't happen to me you know this
is something we're talking about
yesterday so it's very important to
understand that kids need to say when
Allah has these rules there's a reason
why and here it's only manifesting now
and society and saying look see what it
exactly does alcohol you know so yeah
Allah says there's Goods and there's bad
but the bads that way that gets and you
could see many of when alcohol when
people are drinking it plays a big part
and you start seeing that more and more
so you know when you're not you know
we'll talk about clubs and say why do
you think they have ladies for free
could you think I've become it was just
come from without
there's a reason right why is it think
about that they'll say you know hey even
it least is so deception Ali makes it
look good it doesn't gonna say no
smoking even for small fee you don't
have it someone's like Joe this is all
good you know you got the person
looks good man it's about this looks
good but that's the deception and even
to a point we've got so deceptions like
you know I was in Al's in San Francisco
and I was reading for mention in Chicago
in virgin airlines it says drop boarding
to Sin City I'm like okay I just left I
said subhanAllah it's like Zen city like
manner
why did roll up and is it you know it's
always like oh yeah but it's is it
because whatever happens is Las Vegas
stays in Las Vegas you don't think I
love those but it's almost so much that
they use it as that punchline don't
worry no one has to know we'll keep it
on the down-low right and that's exactly
why the police want it's like but that's
the thing and keep your love to learn to
look you do this it will come out it
will manifest and then what if it
doesn't happen now am I happy a few
years from now if not it'll happen in
the hereafter and that's why we're
trying to get kids to understand you
can't and that's good that's a good
title right there if I had them in the
fruit I just take a bite out of class
well no cigarette companies they spend
hundreds of millions of dollars on
marketing campaigns to pick you know in
many cities these billboards are right
outside of school so and like he said
you know DoCoMo looks good that's a good
they know exactly the same Han knows
exactly how to you know market who you
and we do poor job as an imam we don't
put job in marketing for a song to
attract people to say come to the
message we're gonna have a real peace
real happiness the message are not
welcome you know and I am walking to
message where some of the parents they
shout on the cake and say it's not
hockey you know this is a message they
make a message involved and you know the
women especially it's now women can't go
to the mustard who said that you know if
the pups our son had two women in the
message without the separation between
women and men and right there they were
praying and women actually spoke
directly to the Prophet and directly to
to Omar you know challenge in in job
equipment so today we bring some
cultural practices that make the message
you know and welcoming to our children
to our youth are women and we end up
with just also spraying the messages by
themselves who are waiting to go to
their grave so we have to do marketing
campaigns by making our community and I
mean people don't want to live a boring
life you know the clubs are promising
banning things that are excited and they
couldn't necessarily see nothing but the
board sitting there you know open your
book and they say you know people love
life and they want to go out so we have
as leaders as principals to make our
school our message really the public for
life for activity for happiness
yeah I think it's it you know this idea
of one of the reasons I think you know
even the book is lot of times they were
young everything that we have to have
our kids just are reading when the
ignorance and you use kind of said what
I think this is what I heard and then
it's very important because if kids
understand that hey Allah has answers
for everything and all you have to do is
just read and take some time and that's
what's the beauty of our Deen is not
about you just as much after you make
forgiveness for me I mom clear and you
start seeing these it manifests now all
over even in Muslim countries where
there are many people who don't read
they just rely on whatever the [ __ ] that
Pro chef says in the months and
sometimes it knows like when I'm in
India and in some places in India if
there's a personal maybe this memorize
Quran doesn't mean he's a [ __ ] he does
memorize sponsor he becomes imam then
they think everything you could ask him
any questions that doesn't mean he might
know the exact answer and that's why you
start seeing some stuff that in some of
the third world countries you're like
man this is kind of borderline
questionable and then you have
individuals you know how Maya had an
opportunity o to Kenya and they have
this one you know area and and and and
then target to the use and you have one
chef you know they speak Swahili English
so you have a shape speaking in Arabic
to them you know just transia book 65
kids are listening but the problem is if
you're not relating to some of the
issues I'm sorry you're talking about he
that would happily the people on 40%
populations on age you have to have this
little stick drug that they use and
they're selling and you had like I was
in Mombasa and what was happening to
Shabaab were coming and recruiting and
what were they going the cafes because
kids are you know playing I could show
you real one I'll give you money for it
too and it's like you have to start
making these kids understand this this
is not easy way out this is not the way
the Dean teach you just do something
like this and you know got your to one
way ticket to gender that's not the bean
and until we start having them read and
understand and that comes back to our
parents also the value of a religious
education but we have someone that says
you know I'll move to the nice community
district neighborhood for academics I'll
go to Kumaon and pay a hundred two
hundred dollars extra our tutor when
someone has to sit what a chef once a
charge ten dollars an hour for Allah
visited me they're asking for money
what have we done you like that the way
you know the beauty of our deal wasn't
that at the prime the scholars were paid
well the judge would pay well why
because you don't want them to be you
know there's Hickman why does it got
personal pizza the guy with the
collector was paid well see there's no
temptation it's just let's make this
happen on the side there's hikmah and
everything that our Dean does and I
think it's very important for us to
start realizing hey parents your need to
if you want in people of high caliber to
go into the Dean they should do it for
the signal on top but also at the same
time you need young you directors and
say you know what I could work into this
thing and have that and have opportunity
to work at an institution where I could
still support my family just reasonable
we everyone who works in the Dean it's
supposed to be like well you're supposed
to live like the humble of the humble
life then who wants to strive to be like
you yes we have stories that you know
that should be humble but that comes in
within sometimes the reality is that kid
doesn't like well yeah that's fine I'll
just do that with I'll get religious
when I get old when I get close to Allah
go to hutch clean slate after that and
there are Mary a righteous woman because
she'll make me really just why did she
marry you know what kind of marry you so
you see this mindset of other guys you
know when we grow up and how people are
talking so lack of knowledge it needs a
really very important understanding to
be not just reading the frown we need to
do that but understanding the Quran also
and our beloved Prophet Muhammad SAW
awesome
definitely the trend in the Muslim
community is to wait and to finish them
in medical degree engineering or a law
degree and then can't get married then
such as life but that's not the approach
the public Sensibility
young people who ever had so this is a
document from the Prophet who is
inspired by the most infallible and
benefits us a lot of 10 of the highly
creative if he wants us to marry at 30
or 40 we have the laid-back but in a
recent news you know study they have
seen and this was from a Princeton
graduate
she herself went through the experience
that he wanted to have a child but it
was too late for her she was in her
forties opportunity finished and she got
the job and now she's a fanatic but then
it was so easy for her to get better
and she wrote a book about this is a
nominee that the either school graduates
most of them work with the women
especially they end up not having
children
it's too late and her best advice this
is another from the public or a Muslim
this is from a person from her own
extension said everyone every woman
going to an Ivy League school should get
married before she starts and she said
your appeal for a man to get married
because it's better to start your life
with your partner knowing where you go
so most moments are advised by the
Prophet to select 2008 on their cloud
early on not based on how he or she has
that medical surgery or law degree or
they have a big bank account which you
choose the person based on their need
based on their a class you will never go
wrong
and you will go together and I
personally went through this experience
myself I got married my wife was still
gradually and then I had a portrait to
go to medical school and hamdullah she
finishes back with his position and I
myself you know we go together we have
children with anything and now I'm
encouraging my 17 year old I wanted to
get married because he is in college if
he had me and he you know went to
college in second year in college so I
know what temptation is out there I
don't know I don't want him to say what
my parents are against I know I want you
to find a person who is good and they're
doing enough laughs and that's my
criteria not necessarily degree or how
much money they come over we as parents
have to take better you know away from
the children where they feel my pension
amenities because they will not let me
choose the person I love because they're
not from my been in town on my city or
my family we had a medical affliction
settings are preventing the young
and I've seen many 30 40 year-old
listens to that professionals for still
waiting I said what are you waiting for
you know the training x-axis buyer who's
gonna go and marry you know 30 40 or old
woman or a man when they can find
someone in this way and that is your
fault you waited and waited thinking
that if I get that degree I'll be more
money to know you want it start early so
I encourage it and stick it to the youth
here by physically get night for me so
that's you know what one is I think for
a young is is to make that relationship
with Allah smile about and it takes time
and that means through Salah I think
it's one of the biggest keys and then
you can try to make that establishment
and hit in the mud said I know a lot of
times now everyone learns online and I
think I worry about that sometimes
because the the Mudgett has there's
there's a reason why the prophets
awesome everywhere you went made them
bill Tomas and I think it's very
important to come there and there's
going to be always some form of politics
and stuff but don't use as an excuse
because that's what the police is
putting in everyone's head I don't do it
the politics but we realized throughout
history the way of Allah Sona is that
everyone he loved it made it he not easy
when the prophets had to work hard they
had to go through back and forth pushing
shut you know going through your tough
times even with their own people so one
is to not give up and then make that
establishment learning the Deen
understand the Deen and making good
friends yeah got to know you know your
heart check your heart you know when
you're doing something wrong and my big
thing right now is the internet internet
internet for the young ones yeah guy to
watch that because this is where I've
seen more kids are at a young age
becoming more mature not really in the
sense of intellectually but what they're
seeing and I think I'm trying to raise
up and they're trying to do some things
that it shouldn't be doing so I think
you know if quickly that I mean those
are are things so one is on that on the
thing of advice what I would said really
the intro
cable and Greeley parents and where the
parents eat to do is really put some
some kind of control like I add my own I
always tell people I have no shame in my
own laptop I have a thing called cyber
patrol cyber sister sitter my wife put
the password on it I said don't tell me
the password
and she has it so anyway you know just
because you never know what email comes
to you why emo could go out so it's very
important so I think that that one
aspect of it and parent is and then for
the young is not always give your kid
hope always give hope do not ever
despair because that's a visa was the
one who despaired adam- on why it was
different because we're in mistake
Ruffin has Ellen on fussing and so on
email is the way that Allah smiles up
and then so that's one thing I want kids
to realize that when you make a mistake
work hard Allah always gives you another
chance
sounds like a video game right but just
but after a while the game might be over
same thing with parents even I know
sometimes take away your pride and know
that this child is going to be your
investments for the hereafter and that
way you'll always will keep on working
on it and I realize that we Shepherds
good to the seat even if the sheet gets
lost
he'll find his way back home since shall
I make dua to Allah sound like helps all
of us and even though some adults
because all of us are still got
challenges it doesn't stop
I am Not Afraid to stand alone get four
lines by my side I am Not Afraid to
stand